tu peux changer de langage ok par celui
que tu désires est ce que j'avais déjà
une idée pour le gaz
j'ai l'impression que cette émission
commence à péter bishop commence à me
plaire fortement
delphine enfin les filles adorent me
donne je me donne aucun nom mais
sincères entre sa plus grande qui est
longue et tumultueuse la montre c'est ça
la touche à tout cela touche là
cela
c'est bien parti
tout cela tout cela
many many as gaye daffé
m'engage alors tu peux changer de gamme
avec la personne de son choix la même
cage comme lé fief avec grand plaisir je
vais faire ça tu
fais ce que tu me yade estime qu'elle a
maintenant c'est
bien
tard et bien
écoutez moi je ne suis pas un crime je
vous faut ancrer madame aime pas trop
mettre en place là bas
du reymond turp à tlr les poussières
s'il te plaît les réalisateurs merci les
cadreurs on y va on est là delphine
face au wat tourner là bas
c'est parti alors au revanche
on veut ce que vous voulez c'est vous
qui faites votre vie seulement voilà moi
vous savez je suis là en cas de coup dur
expat laon sauveteurs à tout moment bien
entendu bien sûr vous n'avez qu'à man à
dire bah bah
non c'est moi qui t'ai drague
hélas le temps des hétéros dans ses
missions
matthew il reste combien
ça mais c'est ouf cette émission c'est
devenu jamais ça rigolait j'adore c'est
comme ça
[Rires]
mais loin derrière est incroyable
[Musique]
ce
qui se passa les deux
noms
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête d'un chat héros